vsauce kevin here with historical proof
that isaac newton was wrong
at least once in his storied career he
seems to have been right about gravity
and calculus and 58 000 other things
that redefined how humans thought about
math and science but here's what newton
couldn't quite handle
[Music]
dice some of ye are gonna think
i'm wrong and others will agree that
newton was wrong
but ye will think that it doesn't even
matter
this will be fun let's start by talking
about peeps
samuel peeps gained fame as england's
chief secretary to the admiralty
and eventually became the sixth
president of the royal society of london
the oldest national scientific
institution
in the world but now he's most famous
for his letters
and meticulous diaries in 1693
peeps sent a dice gambling problem to
one of the most
brilliant mathematical minds alive
sir isaac newton it's the only time
newton
seems to have worked on probability and
even though he was mostly right
he was still a little bit
wrong here's how peeps made a wager with
a man named
john smith over which of the following
scenarios was the most likely to occur
or if they were all equal a has
six dice in a box with which he is to
fling
a6 b has in another box
12 dice with which he is to fling two
sixes c has in another box 18 dice
with which he is to fling three sixes
q whether b and c have not as easy a
task as
a at even luck peeps problem
isn't hard to figure out until it is
on the surface is it easier to get 1
six in six dice or three
sixes in 18 dice or is
there no difference at all in terms of
probability
peeps posited that c with three sixes
in 18 dice was the most probable
more dice better odds
hey what are we even doing with ye
dice we're using standard six sided dice
with each
side equally likely as an outcome no
funny business here the odds of getting
a six on each individual roll
are a simple one in six now we just need
to fling them wait
we've got a language problem is the bet
here to find out whether we're flinging
a
six or does that imply at least
one six because exactly one
six and at least one six are two
different things
and that would apply to b and c two it's
a critical point in figuring out exactly
what our odds are and whether there is
any difference
as they exchanged letters newton
interpreted peeps problem
as being satisfied with at least the
minimum
number of sixes and while peeps
predicted that the best
shot to win was rolling at least three
sixes
and a fling of 18 dice newton proved
it was the opposite a is most likely
b is the next most likely and in
ye third case yi value will be found
still less and i know that people
don't believe this there are articles
written to this day
300 years later claiming that the
probability
does not change when ye add dice
after all every die has that one in six
chance of coming up
six and a set of six dice is really just
six individual dice 12 and
18 that's just two and three sets of six
but
they're wrong and i'll show ye why it's
time to prove this by
flinging some dice mathematically all
the possible probabilities of an event
need to add up to one so in a coin flip
there's a 0.5
probability of heads and a 0.5
probability of
tails and the probability of one of
those two
outcomes occurring is 0.5 plus point
five
equals one because one of those two
things
is certain to happen and it's the same
with our dice game
so to find the probability of something
happening it's usually best to calculate
the probability
of that thing not happening and then
subtracting it from one
those are the only two outcomes here it
happens
or it doesn't so that calculation
everything minus failure leaves us
with the probability of success the
probability of rolling a six
is p hold on i gotta i gotta find my
marker
probability of finding my marker one
hundred percent
the probability of rolling a six is p
so p equals one over six the probability
of
not rolling a six is one minus p
so the probability of not rolling a six
with six
dice our a scenario is one minus p
raised to the sixth power plug in the
one over six
value for p and the probability of
rolling at least one
six with just six dice equals 0.6651
dot dot dot we do the same thing for b
it's not any more sophisticated there
are just more
terms and a little extra step since
rolling
only one six in 12 dice is now
considered
a failure 2. so the probability of b
equals
1 minus p raised to the 12th power minus
12 over 1 times p times 1 minus p
to the 11th power that simplifies to
1 minus 1 plus 11p times
1 minus p raised to the 11th power and
when we put in
our 1 over 6 value again the probability
of succeeding in scenario b
is 0.6187 it's about
five percentage points less than the
odds of winning with only six dice
and that's actually about a seven
percent swing in
outcomes and like newton said
c is even worse ye value will be found
still less
turned out to be 0.5973
but newton didn't actually calculate the
third scenario he
had to calculate all of this math by
hand
not using the simple probability
notation we just used and
he actually made a really detailed
series of tables
that peeps could use to do the
calculations himself
newton's tables used first principles
basic knowledge rather than
complicated specialized knowledge so
peeps could confirm the calculations
like this
and plug in his own values so
for example the probability of at least
one six and a toss
of six dice is obtained from column f
by dividing row nine outcomes with at
least one
six by row two total outcomes for the
dice throne
it's simple elegant genius i
and ye can do it a lot more simply and
crunch the numbers on a calculator or
run a simulation of say 100 000 trials
of 18 dice
rolls and just a few seconds to confirm
the result but
if ye want tables like peeps ye
got tables isaac newton didn't have
those computational tools and to be
honest he
wasn't that familiar with probability no
one in the 17th
century was and that's why he got the
numbers right
and he got the reasoning wrong
in 2006 stephen stigler a professor of
statistics at the university of chicago
detailed a serious flaw in newton's
logic
as the correspondence evolved newton
assigned scenario a to a fictional man
named peter
and scenario b to james he explained
that
peter only needed one six in his fling
of six dice
while james needed a six in each fling
of six dice
so it was easier for peter to win
same with the unnamed player c who's
flinging 18
dice newton completely ignored the
possibility of
getting more than 1 6 in each fling
and that's just a different problem than
the one
we're dealing with here if that seems
like a minor detail
it really isn't yeah his explanation was
wrong but his answer was right
and that seems to be enough for most
people almost
no one talks about how his conclusion
was wrong and that's what's amazing
about this problem
to me does it matter if ye are wrong
about why ye are right
on december 23 1693 in his third letter
on peep's dice problem
newton's explanation conflated that
original language problem
i pointed out whether we're hoping to
get exactly a number of sixes or
at least a certain number he
was confused he knew the math and he
nailed it despite probabilistic thinking
not even really being
a thing in his era but
his reasoning couldn't quite catch up to
the numbers
that's okay and for centuries we
kind of let that go part of it was that
it took a long time to develop
enough knowledge to know why newton's
explanation
wasn't exactly right probability
seems to have evolved from wanting a
better
understanding of gambling and the
numbers
were accurate and part of it was that
he's isaac newton no one's making a
career disputing the details of a man on
humanity's mount rushmore of math
and science except stigler
and i i guess
but the newton peeps problem shows us
how
numbers can't just exist on their own
they work
hand in hand with our understanding of
the problems
they're applied to and really newton's
solution is evidence that occam's razor
is right
that the simplest method is probably the
right one and the
simpler sequence of events is probably
going to work
more often we use that mindset to
develop and
improve everything from manufacturing
and assembly lines to
coding software for sustainability
we need it to progress
the important thing is someone needs to
get
complicated about getting simple to
prevent
seemingly simple things from getting
suddenly
complicated which makes
things simpler for us so that
we can move on to things that are more
complicated
and as always thanks for watching
you